[Musique]
non
depuis quelques mois les ministres
guettant barrette est attaqué de toutes
parts il refuse de donner suite de
prendre des mesures concrètes immédiates
il a perdu totalement la confiance du
public
on remet en question certaines de ses
actions et son style de gestion moment
on est un peu et on leur quota certains
vont jusqu'à manifester pour réclamer
cette démission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gaétan barrette avait pourtant été très
clair quand il s'est adressé pour la
première fois au gestionnaire du réseau
à peine deux semaines après avoir été
nommé ministre de la santé combien vous
allez dans notre direction
ou bien vous y y et les pauvres et si
vous y allez pas là il va y avoir des
conséquences quatre ans plus tard le
ministre de la santé est fragilisée mais
il revendique le droit de faire les
choses à sa façon
je n'ai pas accepté les médecins de la
santé pour faire de la méditation
transcendantale et où la lévitation
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
concentré d'assises comme un gros jeu de
mécano donc chaque peuple a sa place
dans cette sculpture marcel landry est
propriétaire de mehdi fils une compagnie
spécialisée dans la construction de
bâtiments médicaux il est en train de
bâtir à deux pas de l'hôpital de saint
jérôme ce qui pourrait bien devenir une
super clean
oui on l'aperçoit ici au centre puis l
objectif de désengorger l'hôpital cheval
saint jérôme est une ville en pleine
croissance et son hôpital on souffre il
est débordé une super clean et qui est
un besoin dans la région
marcel landry a déjà conclu plusieurs
ententes avec des médecins mais un
dossier capital reste à boucler son seca
saint-girons il va avoir un lien on se
pose une origine
un line c'est un laboratoire d'imagerie
médicale une clinique de radiologie sans
l'hymne les médecins du pôle santé
n'auront pas accès rapidement aux tests
dont ils ont besoin pour soigner les
patients parce que ça vous inquiète tout
était pourtant bien harry né c'était
avant que le ministre guy temps barrette
décide de faire le contraire de ce que
lui recommandait le comité qui avait
pour mandat de le conseiller
en tant que président de l'association
des radiologistes du québec le docteur
vincent oliva faisait partie de ce
comité composé de médecins et de
représentants du ministère
les experts du ministère ont fait le
travail terrain pour eux
premièrement évaluer les besoins puis
deuxièmement évaluer quel groupe était
plus apte à répondre à ces besoins le
d'un côté il y à groupe radiologique une
compagnie qui possède déjà une douzaine
de l'hymne de l'autre il y as docteur
jean-françois dit et un radiologiste de
l'hôpital de saint jérôme
celui ci a déposé des documents qui
indiquent que son projet jouit de
l'appui de l'ensemble des radiologistes
de l'hôpital mais l enquête terrain du
comité révèle que ce n'est plus le cas
on avait des échos assez directe et des
discussions qui avec ses radiologie cela
qui nous disait on pense qu'on sera pas
capable de répondre à la demande on est
déjà débordé dans la région
dans sa présentation groupe radiologique
ce fait miroiter un réseau provincial
d'une cinquantaine de radiologistes
attiré jx a mené une expertise et un
réseau de radiologistes qui était
capable de si on veut à 1109 amener des
bras dans cette région là pour aider la
population de saint jérôme la
candidature du docteur guité a du plomb
dans l aile
les vérifications du comité révèle que
plusieurs radiologiste de l'hôpital ne
veut plus s'associera avec lui il ya des
facteurs humains qui ont été prises en
compte dans cette décision là des
facteurs de relations humaines qui font
en sorte qu'il ya des gens les fois
qu'ils peuvent s'entendre un petit peu
moins bien ou moins faire l'unanimité
avant de venir s'établir à saint jérôme
le docteur guité a travaillé à l'hôpital
de moncton et là non plus il n'a pas
fait l'unanimité
il a fini par intenté une poursuite
contre des collègues les accusant
d'avoir comploté pour ruiner sa
réputation et lui faire perdre son
emploi dans leur défense les collègues
allègue que le docteur guité a fait
l'objet pendant cinq ans de plusieurs
plaintes relatives à son comportement
la poursuite s'est conclue par un
règlement suivi d'un désistement pour
nous il y avait un risque si le groupe
de saint jérôme ou perez les bleus le
risque étant qu'il ne serait pas capable
de livrer en temps opportun les soins
auxquels la population de saint jérôme
est en droit de s'attendre
les huit membres du comité sont unanimes
il faut donner le permis au groupe
radiologique ce méguétan barrette en
décide autrement
même si son cabinet a été informée qu'un
seul radiologiste de l'hôpital appuie
toujours le docteur guy t il annonce son
intention de lui donner le permis
le docteur guide et je ne connais pas je
n'ai aucune relation
j'ai jamais vu d'internet et je ne
tenais pas non plus son mode de
fonctionnement avec ses collègues elle a
d'ailleurs quitté n'est pas éternel ce
qui vous sera permanent par contre c'est
la laboratoire d'imagerie médicale pour
inciter le ministre à revenir sur sa
décision
groupe radiologique ce fait parvenir au
ministère une lettre signée par la
majorité des radiologistes de l'hôpital
disant qu'ils appuient radiologique ce
ça faisait quoi ébranler son petit nez
très la porte tout et je pense toujours
au dans tous les corps qu'il est
préférable que ce soit les reds l'égide
de la région qui s'occupe de la région
il prend ses décisions selon sa vision à
lui
cette source a requis l'anonymat parce
qu'elle travaille toujours pour le
ministère de la santé
les gens présentent des dossiers avec
une documentation très étoffé et il peut
décider complètement le contraire parce
qu'il a une autre opinion il détient la
vérité
c'est lui qui l'a le leem de
saint-jérôme n'est pas le seul dossier
où les conseillers du ministre ont mordu
la poussière
le chu sainte justine
c'est la plus grande unité de
néonatalogie au québec en 2015 l'hôpital
sainte-justine veut ajouter 15 lits à
son centre de néonatologie un expert du
ministère étudie la situation et estime
qu'il faut refuser les services s'étant
développée dans plusieurs hôpitaux
sainte justine n'a pas besoin d'avoir
plus de lits malgré la recommandation de
l'expert le ministre autorisent les lits
supplémentaires mais précise qu'ils ne
pourront être utilisés qu'en situation
de débordement
la décision les trains clair nous
opérons 65 lits mais nous équipons par
sécurité 90 c'est la décision que
j'étais prêt
et et 2014 le nouveau chum est en
construction
le directeur général demande que 24 lits
de soins intermédiaires soit ajouté au
66 lits de soins intensifs qui sont
prévues à deux reprises
malgré une révision des coûts à la
baisse par le chum le sous-ministre
adjoint refuse la demande
il invoque une quinzaine d'arguments
dont des coûts d'opération annuels
élevés méguétan barrette renverse sa
décision il autorise les lits
supplémentaires
une décision était prise et c'est celle
qui était souhaité par le corps médical
auchan son réseau de médecins
spécialistes de conseil et l' influence
beaucoup plus que ses experts son équipe
on a beau lui dire qu'on est bien nantie
en service spécialisé son réseau les
fluence puis il augmente encore plus les
services spécialisés
le ministre revendique le droit de faire
les choses selon sa vision si vous
voulez que les fonctionnaires prennent
toutes les décisions et qui a eu aucune
intervention du ministre promotion d'un
nouveau système politique au québec
selon les documents que nous avons
obtenu l'ajout de lits au jeu mais à
sainte-justine devait coûter environ 4
millions de dollars et allait entraîner
des frais d'opération supplémentaires
chaque année
c'est très préoccupant ça veut dire que
cet argent là n'est plus disponible pour
d'autres projets pour des services à la
population par exemple qui sont beaucoup
plus indiqué les experts vous avait
recommandé de parfaire la dépense encore
encore une fois je vous le rappelle
c'est vous pensez qu'il est inutile
délire des gens pour occuper un poste de
ministre mais il dit l'air la télévision
lorsqu'il dit dans le fond c'est au bout
du compte c'est moi qui décide alors
suis-je pas d'accord du comité d'experts
le fep aux 6-10 comme je pense ça vaut
michel gervais a croisé le fer à
quelques reprises avec et en barrettes
il a été gestionnaire de haut niveau
dans le réseau de la santé
il est très critiques du style barrette
l'autocrate ils changent pas d'idée il
signe et c'est tout alors il fait comme
il pense n'est pas besoin des autres
danger c'est que si vous vous trompez
c'est très grave parce que vous avez
épousé une solution qui n'est pas où ça
va avoir des conséquences négatives dans
le cas du leem de saint-jérôme guettant
barrette a imposé un radiologiste qui
n'avait pas l'appui de ses collègues
la suite des événements va l'obliger à
renverser sa propre décision
après la pause une mystérieuse lettre
qui met le ministre de la santé dans
l'embarras
[Musique]
à travers son passé
je
justement vous avez un talent pour
interpréter des documents qui vous sont
fournis vous avez une lecture bien
biaisée du droit madame roy franches
madame marois interviews et le ministre
de la santé s'apparente parfois à un
sport extrême qu'est ce que ça vous est
déjà arrivé de favoriser des ennemis ou
détriment de la population n'ont
absolument pas été rencontré des
journalistes qui faisaient des
supputations comme celle là est ce que
vous voulez je n'ai pas je vous invite à
la plus grande prudence
le 14 novembre dernier excédé par nos
questions la dernière l'achat le
ministre a profité d'un problème
technique
oups il intervenu pour mettre fin à
l'entrevue jose exemple une heure vous
voulez pas je serai prêt de la dernière
question bonjour l'avant
pendant l'entrevue
nous n'avions pas eu le temps d'aborder
un dossier important
à notre grand étonnement
deux mois après notre première rencontre
le ministre a lui-même repris contact
avec nous alors monsieur bara tête à la
réception
il est venu dans les bureaux denquête
l'atmosphère était tendue
la dernière fois on avait parlé donne
aussi que vous avez nommés vous même le
5 juin de la rive-sud ouais en fait deux
sources nous avait fourni beaucoup
d'informations confidentielles sur
projet d'envergure qui revenait ni plus
ni moins à créer un nouveau centre
pédiatrique sur la rive sud de montréal
en regroupant les services spécialisés à
l'hôpital pierre boucher
selon ces sources le projet avait été
mis sur la glace jusqu après les
prochaines élections pour des raisons
politiques
pierre boucher 1 située dans le comté de
la péquiste diane lamarre est bien
connue entre le ministre et la critique
de l'opposition en matière de santé
c'est la guerre pour glaner trois
exemples de façon dont le ministre
plutôt que de répondre à la question me
donne des attributs architecte d'une
épilepsie parce que j'avais des absences
le ministre at il mis le projet sur la
glace pour des raisons politiques des
six muet chez les décisions sont prises
sur la base de la couleur d'un comté
dans ce ministère de la santé dans ce
monde aussi je le prends très
personnellement et je trouve cela
inacceptable
un comité de 13 experts a planché sur le
projet et a accouché d'un rapport final
en janvier 2017 selon nos sources et nos
demandes d'accès à l'information
le projet n'a fait l'objet d'aucune
communication importante depuis
moi j'ai des courriels qui parle de mai
2010 y est et après et à trop manger
seul le ministre veut nous démontrer que
le projet n'est pas sur la glace
il nous présente une lettre du ministère
qui indique que le projet suit son cours
mais j'ai ici on doit confirmer déclaré
dans des services pour la 15 juin 2010un
j'ai fait ça on voit bien qu'il ya un
grand nombre de donneurs en apprenne on
voit bien là qu'il y a
actuellement il y avait
2007 la navette était assez langue des
débats qui se faisait encore à
l'intérieur
évasion la date de cette lettre cette
lettre nous ne l'avions jamais vu nos
sources non plus cela soulevait des
questions
après l'entrevue
nous demandons au ministre de nous
fournir la preuve qu'elle a été envoyée
si ce n'est pas le cas cela pourrait
confirmer ce que nos sources nous disent
le projet importante pour la population
de la rive sud est sur la glace
une semaine après l'entrevue
[Musique]
le ministre parle ici de la secrétaire
du sous ministre responsable du dossier
il emporte cette lettre annonçant que la
mise en oeuvre de la phase 1 du projet
pouvait commencer n'a jamais été envoyée
elles étaient adressées à neuf des plus
hauts gestionnaires des établissements
de soins de santé de la montérégie
elle leur donnait des devoirs à faire et
un échéancier plessis selon gaétan
barrette
elle n'aurait pas été envoyé à cause de
l'erreur d'une secrétaire et personne ne
s'en serait aperçu pendant un an
c'est possible mais difficile à croire
[Musique]
car vous avez quelqu'un qui est auto iv
comme si ça peut être
il peut par exemple prendre des
décisions pour son image pour son son
prestige pour parce que ça fait son
affaire politique match était insiste
c'était ça peut arriver sur ce danger
potentiel
michel gervais ne connaît rien au projet
de la pédiatrie sur la rive sud
mais il connaît le style barrette et
s'en méfie c'est peu comme ce qu'on
dirige une grande organisation un leader
c'est pas sur ses pas c'est pas
quelqu'un qui fonctionne de haut en bas
comme ceux à coup de décrets de
directives à se mêler de tout dans le
cas du futur l'hymne de saint-jérôme
guette en barrette n'a pas tenu compte
de la recommandation de ses conseillers
les stores et un style lots distincts
d'autres styles 2010 que vous allez
avoir cessé maul boss
il a donné le permis d'opération au
docteur guy tu es plutôt qu'à groupe
radiologique ce et ceux qui risquait d'
arriver arriva
[Musique]
le promoteur marcel landry et dr guité
n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre
dr guité n'a pas trouvé de nouveau local
qui conviennent au ministre il n'a pas
réussi non plus à regagner l'appui de
ses collègues radiologiste résultat le
ministre lui a retiré le permis qui lui
avait accordé dans une longue lettre
qu'il nous a fait parvenir le docteur
guittet précise qu'il n'a aucun problème
relationnel avec ses collègues et que la
perte de leur appui est le résultat d'un
travail de sape de ses concurrents selon
lui cette perte d'appuis n'est qu'un
prétexte utilisé par le ministre pour
lui retirer le permis
la décision lui semble davantage liées à
la situation politique et médiatique
actuel du ministre il conclut en disant
que le litige de moncton n'a aucun lien
avec la situation à saint jérôme
aux dernières nouvelles un autre
radiologiste de l'hôpital s'est associé
à groupe radiologique pour faire une
nouvelle demande de permis
le processus d'attribution de permis est
à recommencer
est-ce que vous conseille aujourd'hui
vous avez fait une erreur en n'écoutant
pour votre comité conjoint pas du tout
pas du tout il a dit qu'il était tombé
dans la marmite de la critique comme
obélisque de l'obélix dans la marmite de
potion magique et que les critiques ça
le dérangeait pas du tout de là à dire
que celle l'influencé poli avec un pot
il était perméable à la critique
le ministre barrette est en poste depuis
près de quatre ans
rares sont ses collaborateurs qui osent
remettre en question publiquement sa
façon de gouverner
derrière son panneau de verre ce
gestionnaire nous a parlé en espérant
faire évoluer les choses
le réseau de la santé c'est un peu plus
de 40% du budget du québec et c'est dans
les mains d'un seul homme avec une seule
vision
alors c'est sûr que nous les
gestionnaires quand on voit ça on est
très inquiets on retrouve maintenant
madeleine roy madeleine pas facile
d'interviewer le ministre non il faut
être bien préparé pour lui donner une
chance par contre ils se rendent
disponibles et il ne recule pas devant
les situations délicates et source d'une
quelques appréciable sauf qu'à sept mois
jour pour jour des élections
provinciales il va encore être sous les
projecteurs un bon moment est un petit
peu dans l'eau chaude au niveau de
l'opinion publique mais aussi au niveau
de son propre gouvernement je vous
rappelle que fait les clients lui ont
retiré la négociation des augmentations
salariales des médecins spécialistes
société un coup ils lui ont retiré aussi
l'application de deux lois fondamentales
dont il s'était dotée pour être en
mesure d'avoir une influence sur la
productivité des médecins c'est un
élément clé de sa réforme il l'a perdu
on dirait que le premier ministre lui
même a par des confrontations que peut
provoquer son mini de la santé alors ça
va être très intéressant de voir les
choses évoluer au fil des mois il a fait
la même
merci restez avec nous après la pause on
vend suisse là où le peuple s'apprêtent
à voter par référendum sur l'avenir de
cette télévision publique
si cette initiative est approuvé c'est
pas compliqué tout ceci on tire la prise
pour licencier tout le monde
[Musique]